[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Niuris was only able to
start her restaurant following
the liberalization of
private enterprise in Cuba.
In 1993, the Cuban government
began opening up the economy.
And in 2011, Cuba
implemented another wave
of free market reforms.
In only five years, the
number of private restaurants
exploded from
around 100 to 1,600.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Currently,
Cuba has two currencies.
The convertable peso, or
cuc, and the local peso.
The cuc is paid to
the dollar at 1 to 1,
while the local peso
is pegged to the cuc
with 25 pesos equaling one cuc.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Despite improved
U.S. Cuba relations,
the U.S. imposed
economic embargo
continues to prevent trade
between the two countries.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Irrespective
of the U.S. embargo,
micro-enterprises cannot
import from any country.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Cuba's economic changes
are having a major effect
on the job market.
In some cases, taxi drivers can
make more money than doctors.
Check out this video
from Seeker Daily
to learn more about how the
economy is forcing Cubans
to make surprising
career shifts.
SPEAKER 2: Today,
private employment
extends to more than 200
occupations, many of which
cater to tourists.
As a result, many Cubans who
are employed by the state,
for instance as doctors,
engineers, and farmers, also
work in their free time as
taxi drivers or servers.
SPEAKER: Thanks for
watching Seeker Stories,
and be sure to subscribe
for new videos every week.